three two
they said we would never return
they said we would never return live
they did say that yet here we are
defying the odds yet again
in fact i don't even know if i'm live if
this is being broadcast
not really sure either so one way oh
here we are it does work
and we're back against all the odds let
me explain to you first what is it that
we're doing here what are we doing
and the h3 um after or ethan and ela
after dark episode one
this is the long fabled fabled third
episode
wow and it's a live episode and
basically what we're doing here is we
are trying to have a fun
more casual episode where we're engaging
with our beautiful lovely fans and
our members uh who will send
us uh suggestions via the live chat and
via our members only discord
we have a just a beautiful conversation
you know there was a lot of debate if
this would be available to members or
the general audience and i think that
in these trying times
we're all ravaged by pandemic
by we're all in dire situation we are
here to entertain and be a light unto
this world and so i say
to the people this is for the people
wow this is for the people am i risking
my career coming to you here live
because you know i uh the cancel
potential
is off the charts this could be the
first and last live stream well we had a
debate before we went live like if this
is even worth
it because everybody's so scared of what
i might do or say
so we laid some ground rules
which i won't say what they are
but we laid we laid some ground rules to
try to control myself but this is what
we're doing we are here for the people
this is going to be taking place now
every friday so it's not
members only yeah it's for everybody
remember the member member participation
only is maybe the best way to say it
yeah yeah but but like to to say i do
i love and appreciate the member support
it's so helpful at this time
when we're losing pretty much i mean
we're we've probably lost like 80
percent of our sponsors
and um the direct support is the future
of this channel i think so we really
thank our members with that being said
welcome to ethan hila after dark why do
we call it after dark
because we pretty much guarantee that
this video is going to get
mature rated age-restricted and possibly
even removed
from the internet because what we're
doing here
i think is fun is to usually when we
make an episode of a podcast
there's a lot of stuff we'll come across
that will say well this is definitely
gonna get age restricted that's one of
them we say well it's not worth it
the other one is this is definitely
going to get
our episode like uh
suppressed for having really heinous
heinous content in it or possibly even
removed from the internet
and so what we're done here today is
because we're being directly supported
by members
we can show
anything i just hope we don't our
channel doesn't get terminated
there's one video that i'm so sure will
get our channel terminated that i'm not
gonna show it to you
i'm just gonna play the audio so you
can't show anything there is a certain
well this one's kind of like criminal
and i don't want to get him in trouble
and i don't want to get a strike either
you guys will see it's the fabled ethan
bradbury man on the street
interviews and what's going on
i don't know if we should just how's the
chat doing do we have any interesting uh
everybody's saying that they paid five
dollars for nothing
because it's public now oh they're upset
that it's public i know but then
everybody was upset that it was members
only so you can't win
well you could cancel your membership if
you paid feel like you paid five dollars
for nothing
it's actually it's like two people that
are just spamming that's okay that's
you know what that's a perfectly fair
feeling to have at this point
but what i would encourage you to feel
is that
you're helping our show continue by the
grace of god
and you are enabling content to exist
for the unfortunate few that cannot
afford to pay five dollars
and you can join our beautiful discord
and communicate to us
it's a beautiful thing let's go ahead
and get started
and you guys just basically on discord
these guys are screening calls and
and comments and they'll pass it to me
as we uh
shredders going nuts what is he yeah oh
they're playing okay i think there's a
chew that's so
this is one video we've avoided watching
because i thought it was like too
violent
just i don't know it's just it's so
bizarre but it's
such an iconic video but now as i
as i look at it i don't know that it's
that bad but we didn't
we never watched it because i guess the
way he slams on the ground is kind of
harsh
but this is one that dan dan you've been
lobbying for this video for a long time
this is maybe my favorite video i've
ever seen on the internet
just hands down it's got 15 million
views on twitter so a lot of people
agree with you so here we go
what the [ __ ] is going on
what accent is that
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're gonna have to do like a taj
pointo slow-mo
rewind
no the rewind
wait do we not have rewind rewind zach
we've never we've
can you get it yeah of course can you
get it while we're live
uh i can try yeah again
i need somebody somebody in the discord
has rewind time for you for sure
hook it up i'm gonna sit here silently
until zach plays rewind time great
okay so what happened what i think
happened is either he's on drugs or he's
responsible for this flood and what
looks like a motel
right but why is he covered in water
what was he doing [ __ ] wet man i
don't know
i think it's okay you think he just
clogged the whole
complex because like
yeah he would have to be on the ground
or
or maybe he's just scared of water and
then he is awesome
he broke the windshield
and he's like all right well see you
guys later with that one
damn what do you think happened i i yeah
i mean
it he clearly broke a pipe in his hotel
room and like it it seems like it was
like completely full somehow i i don't
know
like i just imagine like pipe and then
well
they have you on record i mean what is
running going to do
well we haven't even made it to the end
of the video at the at the very end of
this video
the camera just pans over and the dude's
just sitting on the car okay five feet
away
he just gives up i think maybe he just
is like water phobic
if anyone if anyone listening has a
theory i'd love to hear it
shredders on the table eating food
psycho dog
it's rewind time there we go
attaboy zack go ahead one more time
it's rewind time ah
it is compliment of blizzard woofie one
of our members i knew
that would come through one of our
audio he's referred to as the audio drop
sim
can i get some eyes
so is he just scared i don't know
no he's he knows he's in trouble but
then he just sits on the curb
where's he going yeah i don't because
why didn't you run he's just getting
away from the water
no what you did why did he stop there
because he hurt himself
do you think he hurt himself look how
hard he hit the cement when he jumped oh
you think he's just injured yeah
that makes sense because you can see he
really
let's watch that again here you can see
oh he gets up but he's
limping he's not all 100 he's like [ __ ]
actually looks fine i gotta say i don't
know it's fine at first but then when it
pans over
copy video address because it's on
twitter
[Music]
well there you have it the forbidden
video
what do people think what happened i saw
a lot of people spamming drugs
and yeah chat is probably involved i
would have a hard time
sprinklers went off oh [ __ ] oh
that's definitely what happened that's
what i thought at first but it's so
much water like maybe they put i guess
maybe i don't know
do they actually maybe smoking crack in
this hotel room is this
livestream gonna be up on the channel
afterwards
yes omar yes oh you're asking a question
from them yes
all right well that's it um i guess
we'll never know honestly
rewind time oh you want to watch it
again will smith
yeah yeah well we've watched it enough
maybe maybe let's
move on wait somebody just asked in a
super chat ela is
the beanie you're wearing when do those
come out i just received a ted hoodie by
the way and there was a red hair
in it uh oh red hair what
did anyone we know have read that's
strange well you can um
email the support i'm sure they'll take
care of it but
the beanie is a this is like a sample
so um i think probably it will come out
in about two months
people always complain that you wear all
these fire ass on released items
the thing is that i like to wear stuff
because it kind of gives me feedback
while i wear it if there's any issues
so i kind of have to tease you guys
but i kind of get to see what people
like too
based on their reaction yeah see how
people respond did you follow this story
about netflix
they put out this show called cuties
yeah about little girls that twerk
and it was and then what was what was
really the seal of the deal was that it
was tvm
wait that was the race only
a show about little girls twerking
i didn't hear that part a lot of people
were upset about the
campaign promotional photo that they put
up that's what i
think it was a whole package issue um
uh netflix cuties poster yeah you can
see it says tvm on it
let's see
uh here look it says
what does it say don't let me down come
on now
i got i'm not seeing it no i swear i saw
it
dawg don't do this did you get trolled
ah
no i saw it
hang on
it looks like i mean that's pretty wild
that's weird
oh then that's not appropriate they're
so young
that's not cool
these are these are young girls this is
not appropriate conversation
stop it god is so beautiful
what do we do about this guy dude this
is just not okay vin is canceling are
you by chance a
executive of netflix
vin diesel how am i supposed to sit over
here when i'm
looking at such beauty disgusting
that's disgusting i'm sick to my stomach
stop it
uh let's see oh this was a nice little
uh
shout out to all the boys oh yeah
a little tick tock shout out to the crew
who says who doesn't believe that any of
us are date rapists
[Music]
the only youtuber man i trust with my
dreams a lot of people in the comics
were saying maybe not zack
i'm just relaying what they said well i
think it was the meme because of the
chris hanson thing i don't think
oh okay yeah because with
i don't want chris finding out anything
so yeah we don't give him any ammunition
better hit that join button there was
one guy that said that he didn't trust
me because i'm too reserved and thinks
that i'm hiding
i'm hiding something well this photo i
definitely i kind of look like a date
rapist in this photo but
i'll take it i don't see that i just
look angry and like
would they rip you
i actually i i find a lot of pop music
through tick tock
songs that i like that i would never
have heard otherwise
you're an official boomerang talk is our
home
oh finally someone who understands me
okay boomer
um anything from the peanut gallery any
calls let's
let's throw it to a call we got anything
interesting
i see that we have a bunch of super
chats that i guess we should probably
read off something let's go okay hold on
a second scrolling up
this is all this is new people so i'm
sorry um
getting used to it brielle's even uh for
real ethan what would happen
to your moves if you had one leg
amputated this is an ongoing discussion
amongst my friends my moves i mean i
wouldn't have any moves i'd have one
damn leg
up really well with a fake leg i
definitely have moves
even with one the thing is that i'm i'm
not like trying to be
self-deprecated or whatever like i'm
just really heavy right now
i'm working on it but it's a lot of
weight for one leg
if i wasn't more nimble okay
maybe like you two years ago i could
bust a move on one leg do i have a fake
leg i mean you know or is it just
one leg i think one leg oh i was going
to say the prosthetic but
i could see you having moves do i get
crutches
uh what does that mean do i have
something or
like you know like a support yeah
crutches you know crutches are right
oh no i didn't know that's what it's
called yes so do i get crutches or just
one leg one guy just one leg one gun
i mean i would be difficult but sure i
would find a way i couldn't possibly uh
describe what it meant
maybe on the floor you could do this
with the homer simpson
thing where you walk in circles you know
i
i don't know man oh the the
that's the curly i think that there were
oh that's the curly
sorry so i'm i'm not old enough i knew i
knew what you meant though
it smells good uh somebody paid ten
dollars uh
to show a shredder please that's ten
bucks just to show shredder i mean
that's a pretty
shredder i feel like sure is being sex
trafficked at this point like
why what because they're paying it's
like hey give me ten dollars and show me
a titty or something
oh it's not your object to be shown
uh for money right now i don't know
where he is he's busy he's a very busy
man
peace and love peace and love peace and
love i'm warning you
uh no more of you with peace and love
um should we talk watch this tucker
carlson segment on wet ass [ __ ]
i don't i just i love how angry people
are all these
never return oh
live what is that they didn't say that
yet here we are oh no it's a double
sound did you open the stream i think
it's you either i don't even know a
phone
but it's the beginning i'm not really
sure either i think you opened it
somewhere here we are me it's not you
i didn't do anything
wait why is there so many there's like
20 okay how long
that wasn't going on for too long no it
just it just started you heard it
immediately
come on dude that's [ __ ] up you guys
remember when we did like
a whole half an episode
that was my nightmare right there i had
like i had the flashbacks
it still did pretty good that was the
weird part about it
people are saying i'm not again
flashbacks yeah i know ptsd
so anyway i mean look
i don't want to offend the conservatives
but you have to admit that it is funny
how outraged
these people have been like that this
like cardi b
making a song about her wet ass [ __ ] is
heralding the end of time
think about it hi shredder we were paid
ten dollars to put you on screen
like would you put okay how about this
you let me put in other terms
would you if someone's like hey here's
ten dollars put theodore on the screen
would you
feel comfortable doing that well they
are
they are always part of the show anyway
so it's kind of true they're already
kind of cast members
right now but yeah it'd be a little
weird to pay yeah i'm not bringing it
i would need at least 100
[Laughter]
no i'm kidding don't donate i'm not
doing that
um it's so cute they're like living
teddy bears
can i tell you guys a story about how
alfredo became
sorry shredder my favorite dog so we
were hanging out with my family the
other day outside
and it was super hot it's been hot
everywhere but
man it was like this day when it was
like 131 degrees in death valley you
know
by the way how can you even be outside
in 130 degrees without not for long
yeah that's a good question
tread you're licking my mic
so everybody i fell asleep outside it
was super hot i was dying
everybody bounced everybody literally my
whole family left me outside sleeping in
this
in the scorching heat i woke up and who
was there shredder even was gone
alfredo was there waiting for me wow the
only one
and he was suffering too i could tell he
was antsy he didn't want to be there
and i woke up and was like dude true
blue right there
alfredo gang for life yeah so then some
people are asking how do they get on a
call
uh so the way that we're gonna be doing
calls is with our discord and i guess
i can just give because it's a little
confusing just an instruction to anybody
that wants to get in
on the discord what you have to do is
once you're a member you go to discord
and you go
into your settings and go to the
connection tab there'll be a thing for
connections
and you link your youtube to your
discord once you've done that
a little button will pop up to join the
server with a few caveats one
it only refreshes i think every half
hour or something so if you just became
a member you might not see it
immediately just
check back in a little bit it'll be
there and two apparently it's not there
on the ios
app for whatever reason because iphones
suck is is just the truth of it
so if you don't see the button go to uh
go to a browser and do it there or just
do it on
a desktop computer uh once you're in the
server that's where we're gonna be
we're gonna be using the voice chat in
discord to bring calls in and you'll
have an opportunity to um
make a comment um our kind of objective
with that i mean
if we can just talk openly about it is
you know we don't really want it to be
like a q a
kind of thing we want we want your we
want your hot takes
we want your hot tape hot takes we want
uh
you know we we want to rate things we
want to we want to debate we want to
disagree discussion we want to discuss
yes we want to talk about
feet we want to talk about feet show
them is that enough discord show them
your head dan show them the dome
what's happening there oh did you not
see his dome no
oh no i shaved my head the other day
boom because he looks so
it was like 110 degrees in burbank the
other day
so i just went for it his girlfriend
okayed it his girlfriend is turning dan
she has some visual things that she
likes that
she's i still haven't seen it wait what
i'm looking at the
i'm looking at the because i'm watching
the stream and it's in delay so
how much of a delay is that yeah take
the hat off everybody's already
commenting on
it in the chat so i think you guys are
like behind
hmm oh are you fast up to date on oh i'm
right
behind you it's really one time
one time and yes the person
yeah that's that's an ever-going thing
in my life so yes
um okay let's let's let's get back in if
you have hot takes let me know
maybe you know what i'd love to hear
from is somebody who thinks
who disagrees with me that wet ass [ __ ]
is ruining the fabric of society
i'd love to have that question you
didn't say that no i want someone who
believes that to come to
talk with me yeah made it sound like
that's what you think no i don't i don't
think that but here's car
tucker believes that we should
and you need to go online what does that
mean general things i just want them to
be over it oh you want people to come
vent
yeah okay cool here's the woman who
sings it cardi b
explaining to women how they can become
more useful sex objects watch
dude that's okay
because your ph balance is off and you
want to know why it's not because you're
born with it it's because that
is dirty wait what about her song makes
them she's the one taking control of
anything the dudes are sub
sex objects in her song tucker
why don't you tuck dude you know what
tucker stands for you know they call him
tucker because he tucks his dick between
his legs and pretends
tucker wish he had a wet ass [ __ ] but
he's just got a dyna little pecker
tiny little pecker tlp
more like mustard yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is awesome
that's garbage you don't need to be a
puritan oh that's garbage
oh we need that as a match that's
garbage garbage
garbage garbage garbage
oh everybody's going to see me did i
notice i didn't
we didn't see that i thought it was i
thought the camera's on me i'm sorry
all right let's see the dome now let's
see it
just look at the camera show your skin
but i've got the buzz going so there you
go
and you guys will see that in like 30
seconds because it is
all right how do we fix this delay
because it's killing money because
i told you not to watch the stream i
knew it would confuse you
well someone has gone watching the chat
well it's a good thing we did because
you didn't show your head
well that's true yeah exactly
aimed
[Music]
now you're one of those guys with shaved
head and a beard shaved head and a beard
baby that's what your girlfriend likes
though right
yeah she was into it because she's she
likes she's been kind of getting you to
grow
out your beard like crazy and put wax in
it yeah she wants like the curly mouth
at least she knows
what she's yeah yeah she's in control
like cardi b
if i if i may say dan i think it looks
spectacular
spectacular zachary wow wow
i do think it looks good yeah thank you
i think it's
it's rocking dude it's [ __ ] badass
whoa zach what is happening
calm down why are you getting funny for
me dude
i mean somebody said dan your super chat
response game is weak hey listen
you know there's a lot of them and we
we're talking about lots of things
we'll just make sure you read up and
then and then well do you want i mean
there's a lot you want me to read
through them well give me the highlights
i mean sure okay
let's see uh uh marshall says uh beefin
and halal
um beef ain't halal beef in
and halal i don't know what does that
mean they paid five dollars to say
beefing in halal so there you go
uh crasher said uh you guys got me in
trouble
i bought the crippling anxiety tea and
now my wife is pissed that i didn't get
her one
oh buy another there you go uh
very few left you and alexander
uh said uh ethan what does vin diesel
think about h3 members
say what well what does vin diesel think
about h3 members
ben are you there
i don't know why he would assume the
gender of our members yeah
we got a lot of male members out there
too a little rude and frankly
uh eugene bean said uh let me get a big
mac
um okay uh sushi bay uh where are you
guys dropping more teddy fresh
sweatpants
very soon very soon there you go
uh taylor will post malone ever come
back on the podcast
i don't know pro i mean dude
the invitation is always open i think
the guy is too busy
yeah i'd like for it to happen but if he
ever wants to i mean
the truth is that i um i've lost touch
with him
more or less really i didn't actually
the last time i spoke to him was
when he donated
[Music]
a year ago now kind of when theodore was
born
was around the time that we lost that we
just
not for lack of trying i think he's just
he's just too big he's i mean not for me
i mean he's just busy there's a lot of
people in and out of his life so
you know i don't i don't i don't hold
any
ill will for the guy i wish him well
sure he's a great [ __ ] dude so
certainly
certainly nothing bad ever to say about
him but uh
i'd love to have him on any time but
yeah i mean first i gotta talk to him
first
right before he comes on this job but
you know
love post right uh shall we continue
yeah uh well i mean i got like i said i
got a lot of super chats do you want me
to go through them all
okay i got a question here people want
me to i guess more of a comment
people want me to put mayonnaise on
dan's dome would you be willing to do
that no
of course not kidding the joke being
that dan hates mayonnaise
would you do it for charity i told
discord was asking me all this man [ __ ]
the other day
and i told them um i would not eat a jar
of mayo for any amount of money
hold on what any amount of money any
amount of money yeah in fact they asked
if i would eat it to save the starving
children
and i i said [ __ ] no let them start
i don't believe you i don't really what
if we get 100 members right now would
you put mayonnaise on your dome live
no no okay no well i mean on the dome
yeah just on your dome not in your mouth
yeah i mean i guess that's different i
don't know
so that's a yes i'll do it how much
members
how much money is going to get paid
though what are you talking about you
get a nice salary
for the show no just for my standard pay
no how much do you need
how much do you need to put managers on
your dome right
i mean i'm moving soon so i got a lot of
expenses there's a shower
here by the way so it's not that big of
a deal do you guys even have mayo here
oh wow sure i think i used it all oh
really we made an egg
salad recently and and
wait somebody gave a hundred dollar
super chat i feel obligated to read this
one uh
money yeti said my fur is looking mean
my bling is looking mean
i'm the richest goddamn yeti that you
have ever seen
let's talk business thank you for the
donation
that is a very generous donation yeah
let's uh continue watching
cardi mother effin that is very nice
thank you
yeah i just saw i just saw that popped
up like i'll give you 100 bucks i'll
give you
yeti's money to mail your dollar for the
mail yeah
not worth it and what is it doing to
them what are they doing
to them what is doing to them people are
getting rich pushing that crap
on the country and they should be are
you getting rich putting
the crap about the crap of themselves
but they're not ashamed of themselves
joe biden just did an interview with
cardi b doesn't do a lot of interviews
he just did one with her he sucked up to
her and called himself
tell me what your fans most say to you
when they communicate with you online
what are they most concerned about
obviously free
free uh college education free medicare
i of course want free medicare
i of course think that we need a free
college ch levels other [ __ ]
they give you a free metro card so you
could travel for you to be able to go to
your school
and of course they give me they gave me
free lunch by the way
we're going to have if i get elected
president free college education
for four years of college flat out
everybody's a promise
i didn't actually know that was part of
his platform at all
so there you go wow i just really like
dog face pony soldier
[Laughter]
i love the kids jumping on my lap
the kids used to come up and reach into
the pool what's that joe biden what
and i've loved kids jumping on my lap
hmm
don't we i mean yeah it's very nice
kid's jumping on us like what are we
gonna say dan
i just i was just still laughing at how
censored her
clip was on the show that you couldn't
even understand what like i heard hot
dog at some point
like i think she said glizzy gladiator
at one point
for a community college everybody wants
to go on and become
a nate become an apprentice free
again we're not being prudish here this
is not james brown
being sexually suggestive on stage it is
the same thing dumb dumb it's just
it's a new generation bro guess what the
world grew up and you didn't
i think he's like this is my hot take so
whatever but
he's just he's literally just preaching
to the choir of old
of just fox news jim yeah it's like he's
just preaching to the choir go online
right now and look up the lyrics to this
song
no and then ask yourself if you were joe
biden
would you suck up to the person who sang
it and ask yourself above
all and ask it more than once what is
this doing to our kids
ask him more than once
ask it a hundred times people pushing it
clearly you're trying to hurt your
children
why is nobody pushing back timmy bruce
is the host of get tammy bruce on fox
nation she joins me
i don't know why he he's just everything
so
has to be so hostile nefarious she's
trying to hurt our kids
we've talked about what put i mean
everybody loves wet ass [ __ ] i love it
except ben shapiro trump definitely
loves it really
valerie valerie is asking for a theodore
update
how is he doing what's he like he's
great
he's doing great he's walking he's
talking
he's trusting he's in the beginning
stages of talking
he's the cutest um
we just keep saying like he's such a
great guy yeah he's a great guy
he's one of the best he's gonna be such
a great guy he's one of the best dudes i
know
yeah he's just so sweet
and he gets really excited when he sees
me now which is cool oh he loves you
he loves you more than i like he keeps
giving stuff to them
yeah he gives me presents all the time
in general he likes
everybody but for some reason dan he's
he loves dan
so there you go take that for what you
will no
i think it means you have a pure
beautiful soul dance generally pretty
good with kids
like friends kids and stuff they they
always like me yeah he's awesome i mean
i feel bad that still obsessed with
trucks still it's crazy
everybody shrugs every time we get a
package
like from amazon he he just goes right
to it he goes tractor
doctor um the only thing that's just
you know the quarantine sucks i feel so
bad because he would love to be
socializing out on playgrounds and all
this but
it's a weird time but i feel like at
least
he's kind of like too young to
understand what he's missing on
but like we have employees that their
kids are
you know at um like high school or just
school
elementary school age and they're saying
that they're really scared for those
kids because they
are like getting depressed and they're
too young to be depressed like that's
just so sad yeah one of our
employees said he has a how old is his
son
he's like eight yes i'm telling that he
said he
he said something really depressing to
him yeah i don't want to miss quote but
he said something like
i mean they're showing signs of like
just being depressed
just being isolated from all their
friends and [ __ ]
yeah i feel so bad for
i think the people i mean this
pandemic's been tough on so many people
but like
one analogy i've heard which is kind of
interesting you can't tour
you can't play live shows think about
all the creatives and stuff
like if the beatles if there was a new
beatles
coming up right now
and this was their time to be out and
touring and their big breakthrough
moment
they can't play they can't go up they
can't do anything and like
how much of human uh how much of
of the course of human trajectory is
being changed by it by
kinds of things like that makes you
wonder
people are asking where is he and they
want to see an ian
ian say hi do you have any comment ian
oh yeah can you guys hear me yeah yeah
yeah what's up
just over here working on the thumbnail
that's it that's why i'm not talking
everybody well yeah we actually just
finished
our episode with andrew yang so
oh dude they went so we haven't
acknowledged that right we just finished
with yang that's going to go up on
monday
it was a really good interview really
wait monday right yes
yes well for members uh sooner i mean
for members we'll get it up as soon as
we can
yeah and start working on it it was
great i love yang he's always
a joy to talk to the guy is so smart and
so insightful and
compassionate too which i think is
really maybe his defining
uh characteristic which makes him such
an interesting guy extremely down to
earth he dropped
several f-bombs while we were talking to
him in just like a very casual way and
just like man
it's just like so cool to hear like a
prominent politician just talk like a
dude you know
like so um
you guys want to watch some dude i was
promised that this video is
the weirdest [ __ ] ever and i don't think
where any of us are going to be
disappointed by it
it's it's titled guy with a hole in his
living room and
uh if you're extremely claustrophobic
this is house hey this is the after dark
people know what they're getting this
way
all in the living room just brace
yourself you love because i don't
i mean it's weirder than it sounds i
think if that's possible
now i've been i've been um
i've been assured that this is
consensual this is like from a there's a
oh no bizarre out there fetish website
no it's not
it's not explicit but no what
bro you are how how do people find out
that's their fetish like what
dude look at his house is decorated it's
funny because it looks like a typical
grandpa's house and then
he's like well i just have a hole in my
living room where i keep uh
guys oh my god
[Music]
is she what he'll probably go down
slowly
oh no
why does she have to be like because i
guess it's part of the whole thing
oh they're making videos this is for
people to consume
exactly but do you know when she is
really freaking out
they probably have a safe word bye
they're so just they're making content
for people to watch
i cannot leave
believe it you don't seem that shocked
i i i'm no ela i'm
the only thing that's making me be able
to stomach this is that
there's a camera and people are able to
walk like multiple times
how'd they even think about that you
never thought about putting someone in a
hole in your living room
people just ended this stuff and somehow
this is sexual for him
i think it's the control thing right i
guess
it's very matter of fact
the police will never think the look
here
it's like mobility mirrors oh wow like
perfect carpet just a total repair for
the carpet
what sure you got
i'm gonna watch the tv
oh wow this is so crazy i'm speechless i
mean i am
this isn't just what and now he's gonna
watch
oh where did these videos go there's a
website
on the house of gordon unassuming
houseofgord.com
no he's just having to be here i like
how it's just like an ordinary guy
don't go to that website by the way it's
insane there's
crazy [ __ ] i was thinking we might want
to blur that
but it's a little too late now well it's
after hours right
we're after hours baby i guess house of
gold what does gourd mean i don't even
want to know
i don't dan something just happened
where i have my document open and just
closes
and i get paranoid that somebody's
logged into my [ __ ]
uh really i mean it's just a tab and
this might be the weirdest video
ever it's pretty weird i have more weird
ones but not as weird as that
i think this is definitely the weirdest
video i've seen
ever really
[Laughter]
it might be yeah it might be i mean it's
hard to top that
but the best is how he just goes and
casually has a beer
and he looks like just like someone's
dad
oh my grandson's coming over so keep it
down
jesus there's this other one this is a
full-fledged uh
channel on youtube called
i actually did a lot of research on this
channel because i was thinking about
making a video about it
[Music]
it's called um
[Music]
let me give you some background cause
i've gone deep into this [ __ ]
braced life and it's all about
these girls and a doctor and they put on
braces
and all the various forms well this
video has almost 8 million views so
somebody's watching it
they also have a patreon weird kiddos
weirdos they also have a patreon
where they're making 5 000 a month
weirdos
even keemstar knows a weirdo when he
sees one
what does keemstar say when he looks in
the mirror weirdos
five thousand dollars a month on patreon
which is kind of surprising a lot
amounts of money for this
pretty good yeah
so here's a little taste of uh braced
life
so this has to be in russia i mean i
can't imagine anywhere else
and um well they they have the same
ensemble they have the same girls and
they kind of swap
but you know there's some freak dude
behind you like chad is saying
wait real quick pause it yeah i don't
know if this
acrobat is saying houseofgord.com just
crashed because
this dude just got hooked up how's the
gourd baby
that one stop stop putting people on
your floor
sounds like no it sounds like yeah
they're weird yeah that's good like i
purposely ignore it oh the person in
your floor i mean
they might need help
i'm setting a bad example for my
followers well that's obvious
that's i mean you don't need to say that
that's obvious
so they go through this whole thing they
do like a real cast
and then they make them go out in public
and try to exist with the cast on
it's pretty epic so they are
people who just love the idea of being
casted yeah it's just super niche dude
well eight million views so not that
well that's well about a million of them
are me
not as niches or podcasts
[Laughter]
i mean that one must have a really
cheeky thumbnail
that's my only guess here let me go to
videos let me keep that badass music on
while i
yeah let's go by most popular is what i
like to do
oh this one has 26 million would you
click that thumbnail i wouldn't think to
click that
no that's scary looking
well that's a good point you do have to
be able to like
use your bowels and stuff if you're all
you have to cut out a hole for it elo
youtube really just highlights the fact
that
look at her girl people are weird oh
dude that's
crazy
i love the music's so inspirational they
always use the same song in every video
it's awesome so it's just asmr for them
so this one i
has 26 million one year ago i would
never click that but
kate's orthodontic headgear face mask
let's dive right in who would things
look like
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know what is the appeal of
that thumbnail
oh this is pretty hype let's
go
let's so my penis
chubbness is at zero percent right now
i'll update you guys periodically it's
like going the opposite way going in
inwards my penis is inverting yeah
do we have any calls lined up i don't
like it
i see lots of people mentioning boogie
in the chat i guess he must have stopped
by
i don't know buggy was here if that's
true hello to buggy
so now she walks around with this dude i
don't know if you guys remember but
people actually used to get [ __ ] like
this on back in the day my brother had
headgear like that what they don't do
that they did
i don't think so maybe they do i mean um
what do i know about
it it seems ancient it seems so ancient
why do you need this whole thing like
it's an accessory bruh
you mean the headgear no but what does
the fan what does it do that you can't
do without the whole
i think it's for real like if you have
my brother had an underbite
yeah so they use it because they need
they need like something to leverage
against
so they pull your jaw out oh really yeah
oh i haven't seen anyone with this
it's true i haven't seen anybody wearing
that in a long time
technology there was a kid that had it
still so i mean i mean
the technology like with the invisaligns
and everything man it's
it's so much better it's true what are
the fans saying
uh i don't see anybody arguing that they
still use it
at least in the uh thing everybody's
just talking about boogie i didn't see
boogie
yeah i mean so this is oh ela this is
the thumbnail
of the last one i mean that's pretty
wild emily
corrective cast but the other one 26
million this one has 7 million
plaster short leg cast with milwaukee
brace
let's check it out oh no she broke her
poor
ankle i love that this got a whole
narrative
wait she's already got a neck brace
what's going on
oh no and she's already got the neck
brace man this four girl's down on her
luck
i know where she can go braced life
yeah you know there's a few people
saying they do still use it it's
probably edge cases but uh wow
dude we gotta get hurt that's gotta be
brutal to have to use that thing
that girl seemed perfectly happy with it
so this is yeah i mean you get the idea
you know
not for everybody clearly but a lot of
people do it for a lot of people
um i got uh some more super chats
uh oh i just showed everybody the zoom
um let's see what we got what we got
uh we read that one okay
uh you all do it
said yo i gotta say again i enjoy large
buttocks and i cannot deny so
thank you very much
is there more clothes matching
planned oh like our outfit today
oh oh we'll think about it
you guys do like think about your
outfits for sure
it's not look at this look at this so
this is apparently you're not
acknowledging
well are we planning do we plan matching
outfits
yeah no okay yeah i told ela i was like
where you can't wear that beanie it's
crazy i think it's cool
i love that beanie i think it's cool
well no i like nothing about the shirt
crazy oh oh oh it is a lot of stripes
going on um
will we ever see a business casual line
from teddy fresh
would love a color block pants suit i
would love that
um maybe hmm
uh when is zach or dan starting a cameo
that's what i wanted to keep dude why
don't you guys want to make that's
you guys are leaving a lot of money on
the table i don't know would you be
okay with us doing that though i feel
like that would be like sacrilegious in
a way though
no you guys can do cameo it's awesome
people want to get it for their friends
for their birthdays what would you
charge for it
25 yeah that seems like a good place you
should do it
hmm i have no i have no problem with you
guys making a little chatter on the side
lately it's like the best birthday gift
i feel like it'd be funny i'll i'll be
watching just know that
checking in on what we're what people
are forcing us to say
oh yeah definitely
you should do it as a pilot program let
me know how it goes
would you just go to the website and
just like put in your info and who you
are i don't really know
yeah it's easy it's easy so anybody can
do it
yeah yeah i mean well the challenge is
finding people who want to pay you to
[ __ ] run
my video right yeah anyone can do it uh
somebody just said uh please release the
ethan bradberry coronavirus
oh that's coming up that's we have
intentions that's the whole part of the
after dark
yeah that's coming up uh can i buy
beanies used by ethan
and do you ship to discussions oh my god
why would you want that
no you can't no i will not enable
such behavior okay um uh the
white and black stripes are giving me
pinstripe vibes teddy fresh
zoot suit coming soon question mark no
probably not a zombie no no no but um i
do love the idea of like
more like suits and stuff ethan should i
get noodles and co or five guys
hmm what's noodles well
probably noodles and co what is that
it's just a noodles and co you just
don't like five
guys it sounds like let's move it on
let's do
uh let's do some woolies do i want to
take a call do we not have one
interesting person to
take a call from there's really nothing
that's popping out holy [ __ ] dude you
guys
are the worst callers apparently how's
it been screening calls zach tell me
about your experience
well there's just been no like things to
get them in the
like vetting on the like voice chat like
called the screen or lobby
like there's just been nothing super
interesting okay what kind of stuff are
you getting because maybe we can direct
people um just bring someone in
bring anybody in let's go pop someone in
okay roll the dice baby
yeah let's roll the dice um
bring him in zach just anybody bring
anybody just anybody on anybody
hold on
i'm trying to move him in the call i
don't know how to do it oh my god
okay let's move on you're inside no
wonder there's been no calls
ian's been doing the discord it's just
nothing's been all right as speaking
i've walked you through it earlier no no
but how do you drag it in there you drag
it you click it
that's what i'm doing it's not going in
all right i'm grabbing someone here we
go grabbing someone moving him
and does zach not have access he does
zach why is it that you click and you
drag
i i'm clicking i'm dragging and it's not
working
garbage garbage garbage
good luck trying to screw me over here
all right
so here's another weird one these women
what i don't know what's the fetish
about are they naked underneath it
what makes it a fetish yeah it says it's
an innocent fetish
they're just obsessed with it i mean
look at that that's that's a fat ass
mother
loving wall i've never seen wall child
oh my goodness
hello i'm i'm intrigued in there knock
knock
oh that's super weird
that is super weird she looks like a
vase
what that's pretty funny
that's a fetish that seems like a gag i
don't think fetish is the right word
here
it seems like a just a straight up gag
oh that's a fetish holy [ __ ]
bro what the [ __ ]
holy crap
i think we need to get an outfit like
this for you yeah
that's something your grandma totally
your style you should ask someone like
someone in the family you know they're
like oh can i make you a scarf or
something
like here can i get one of these my mom
um everybody's saying you can't get in
the discord i
i gave i gave you a heads up at the
beginning the discord takes a little bit
to sync
so if you just signed up to be a member
it's going to take like 30 to 40 minutes
before
you're able to get in there so just give
it a little time yeah really because it
just periodically syncs with you
with the youtube account so it's not
instant unfortunately
can you guys get somebody to call i want
to talk to the people
anybody
garbage
garbage hello we're working on it we're
working on what so
so it doesn't work or it does work i
can't drag for some reason
but ian can you do it
sounds like maybe there is a problem
okay okay it wasn't it wasn't young
zach's fault after all
[Music]
can you guys just update me so i'm not
sitting here screaming like a
psycho ian what's the update
yeah uh there's yeah here's one right
now
hello hello all right oh hello
who we got hey what's up what's up
what's your name not much uh i'm scott
but in the
discord i go by ginger beard man ginger
beer man you have red hair
i do i do are your pubes red
i sure are interesting are the color of
the pubes different than the hair on
your head or is it exact same color
it's a bit lighter like my body hair in
general is a bit lighter than
my facial and head hair so the pubes are
like bright red
no they're like a reddish blondish kind
of
they're still ginger but they're not
like as fiery orange as like the beard
and stuff oh i see i see
and then yeah interesting so do you find
i know a lot of women are into redheads
do you find that to be true
i found that there's a very particular
cast of women that like redhead
yeah it's you hear you keep hearing like
oh women love redheads and it's not like
a million women but when you find the
ones that do it's like they're really
into it like that's what's up because
they're all about that redhead life
that's awesome so have you been with a
girl who's like
into that redhead life uh
i got i was like i was like went a
couple dates with one but then she was
like
[ __ ] crazy so i dipped out of there
that's a shame did you get to see your
fire pubes
no we didn't get that far
so um so how can we help you today
nothing man i just you guys were like
wanting so many calls i was like dude
just
[ __ ] call me and ian was like hey you
want to be on i was like sure
like there's tons of people just like i
guess like you said none i guess they
just thought none of the people posting
and they were good enough so i was like
[ __ ] call me i was like i'm the best
caller just you know it's like i don't
know anything to get
attention just to stand up well
so what do you do what do you do in your
life
right now who are i just got a drone so
i've been doing a lot of drone stuff
recently taking some photos and
and that kind of stuff how many are you
virgin or has anyone seen your fire pew
oh my god i am not a virgin no yes
people have seen my fire cube
well i just i'm intrigued by that dream
by the fire
yeah it's fair well what is it uh
so what's your origin are you from like
ireland or
not ireland scotland where the where's
the red hair from uh well it's a
recessive trait so can you like anybody
can kind of have it but i do
have like european like germany check
and like a little bit of irish
like in my family history hey uh
so sorry to interrupt um pewdiepie just
became a member of the channel
oh how nice let's get him on discord
quick
pewdiepie [ __ ] pewdiepie
that's good pewdiepie on call cause he's
supposed to be here i heard he's
supposed to be on the podcast next week
next week that's actually
that's accurate i forgot my own joke
because once he actually came on we
stopped doing it
he said just join three sub where's the
fit
pick oh pewdiepie is a tier three sub
you want to see my
everybody go to wikipedia and rate me
five stars and everybody go to
keemstar's wiki feet and give him zero
stars
[ __ ] start thank you very much for
saying that well i've
really enjoyed talking to you and
learning about you
thanks for having me guys yeah thank you
and thank you for being a member and we
love you and appreciate
you and keep the do you trim the pubes
or you just let them go
uh when i'm not when i'm out with
anybody just let them go but
if my partner has a preference i'll
happy to
very good well how do you know they have
a preference you know because
i i still love communication man you
gotta you talk to your lady yeah but
when you first have sex you don't really
have time to ask what your preference is
you know what i mean well maybe you
don't my sex life is a little different
i like to communicate before i go and do
the deed
so your dates so you go on a few dates
and then you're like um tonight's the
night maybe the third date or whatever
or maybe
i don't know what the timeline is for
you but you say listen you just you just
casually bring it up you you start
talking you do a little the flirty and
the dirty and then you're like hey how
do you you know how do you prefer it you
know and then
wow she's like dude we haven't had sex
why are you asking me about pubes
i mean because you know you shout very
conversations where you're clearly like
we might be moving towards that you're
like oh what do you like what are you
into
i'm preparing for uh the inevitable i'd
like to
gauge your interest on public so
in those situations are the girls um
they they just go along with the
conversation and uh let you know their
preference
yeah sure if you if you don't feel like
weird and awkward about you don't just
like
just you know you don't start out flat
off like hey how do you prefer my
you know stuff but if you're talking
about you know sexual topics already
you're just like hey how would you
prefer
this guy gets it yeah how do you keep
yourself how do you guys a good lover
it's kinda it kind of makes sense
this is a good lover you could be uh
you're sexy
i can already tell let me ask you this i
i think it's fair to assume
most women like it trim though i think i
could go on a list
because like i used to have a wild like
going into college
like i i was a virgin right but then the
first time i had sex
i was 19 years old i was my freshman
my freshman year of college and i had
never trimmed my pubes before
and they were wild bro and let me tell
you like
the girl she made one comment to me she
says
she she laughed and she said your pubes
are huge
and i was like do you want me to cut
them and she and but i think she was
embarrassed because she was she was just
like no i'm just
never seen pubes that big yeah i think
the the consensus i've heard from like
partners and just like
talking in general is most women of
course not all because you can't say all
but
prefer something they prefer some
but not like the full bush not a black
like just
and not small yeah not wax that's what i
found too kelly
kelly here just said i don't like it
trimmed you like a bucket lots of raw
what do you got a guy with a real small
dick like me and then the pubes are
longer than the dick i mean that's not
sexy
i mean it might be this would be the
best thing just go with the trim so it's
not full
like your beard i mean you just you any
of your body here just keep it nice and
clean well what's your preference do you
prefer it shaved or wild
i'm i'm not going to turn any you know
if i'm into the person i'm not going to
turn them down but uh
i'm a bushman i don't mind some voices
interesting i like that i like the
natural you know i don't want my my you
know i'm an adult i don't want him
looking like you know a little girl
you know i want at least a little
something like it doesn't have to be
like
[ __ ] jungle but you know show me here
you know ladies
that's fair well thank you very much for
the inside i've had a great conversation
with you and i wish you all the best
thanks for having me guys
there you go you see that how great of a
conversation
that was beautiful i mean
touching uh illuminating i mean i kind
of feel like
it kind of blew my mind with the fact
that he just
he's so confident and he has a problem
like in those questions i do
kind of have some doubt about it though
because
if i'm in a the dating phase
i i feel like that's a question for
after you've had sex
because the dating game has changed
since you were yeah you're in it like
yes we've been together for a long time
well what what i would do
is keep it trim and then once you've
established
some sort of relationship ask if they
have a preference
because the trim is not going to offend
anything
okay but just like okay so uh we're
gonna be
having sex tonight and i was just gonna
go into the bathroom and
uh use the clippers so i was just
wondering
have you ever you know what i used to do
use the same clippers for my pubes and
face i think you've mentioned that but
it doesn't it didn't bother me because i
always shower afterwards so i'm like
what does it matter you know not a big
deal
i think the trick is to do your beard
first
and then
ideally you should probably have
separate
well it's like so many gadgets oh well
look at you richie rich
two different spirits i'm not walking
around with two different
beard traps real quick i saw a super
chat which seems relevant um
yaki yaka boys just said um just asked a
girl out that i've known for seven years
she said yes please give me some dating
advice i have no idea what i'm doing
i think we should right now call in
get him to call him yeah boy if you're
in if you're in the discord um
we'll we'll pull you in but i think on
your first date you should make sure to
ask her
so um i got a question from kelly here
who is wondering what is my skincare
routine
and she's asking if eton has one too and
um i constantly try to find a routine i
keep trying different products and i
feel like i just don't know what i'm
doing
and i keep getting ripped off um
that's very true my basically what i
like to do
is have a nice like
moisturizer face moisturizer sunscreen
in it mine actually doesn't have
sunscreen in it
avoid the sun i mean i think every guru
agrees avoid the sun
but um i put it on in the morning
and then i put it on again in the
evening and um
i use a face wash when i shower
you're over it no no i just felt like
pushing the button i'm sorry
no i didn't mean to say that um
it's yeah that's it here's my take on it
i
i've looked into this a lot i think it's
all [ __ ] i'm always buying like a
different moisturizer a different face
wash
it's like a multi bazillion dollar
industry and like you either have good
skin
or you don't have good skin it really
just comes down to
exfoliating removing the dead skin from
your face you could do that with
the celic acid you could do that with
manually scrubbing it off with
anyone is more knowledgeable about this
stuff than me well i don't really take
good care of my facial skin to be honest
because like
when i'm in the shower i remember a
dermatologist told me when i was young
he says you know shampoo is generally
pretty gentle on the skin so
i use my shampoo to wash my face that
sounds crazy to me
i mean i don't doesn't get your face dry
oh well face wash dries it out a lot
more
yeah this is me trying to
this is i won't lie this is me when i
try
buying skin care products
so anyway here is a crackhead falling
through a uh the roof of a restaurant
i have actually a funny story about this
stuff i don't know if i told it
on the podcast i don't think so though i
i was using this product it's called
i think drunk elephant
right yeah so
they have this like series of uh
whatever face moisturizers and stuff
so i was using that one and i went to
get a facial
for like blackheads and they asked what
is your
routine what do you use so it was a guy
who was asking me what do you use and
stuff and i said
um i just used this company the naked
elephant
and it was like what like it looked so
weird and i was like i don't know that's
i just used the moisturizer i thought i
was like it was shocked that i'm like
that's the only thing i'm using
or anyway i said it wrong right
he's like that's a hit it's not the
naked though everybody's saying drunk
elf yeah drunk
oh that's like a famous product that's
hilario this is you
trying to tell the dermatologist what
product you use
stupid story move on bruh
it's not stupid either don't don't it's
awesome
it was awesome story here's a crackhead
falling through the roof
[Music]
apparently they can i can't hear
anything but they know he's there
[Music]
oh my god awesome
i love how it wait it doesn't end there
oh it ended there i mean i'd like to
know what happened
so there's a crackhead falling through
the roof
and i oop crackheads and the roof be
like
and i oh and i oop so i got uh there's
a ton more super chats i know we can't
like get to them all uh i saw
i saw one that was like huge though hold
on a second somebody donated like 150
bucks or something oh wow
i gotta call that one out one second yes
where the hell did you go there's so
many thank you
we appreciate it i'm sorry we're not
getting to everybody but there's just
thank you thank you thank you stupid
opinion on jenna leaving the platform
and the podcast
i feel pretty sad um tragic
it sounds like she's having a really
hard time and she's in a dark place
right now
just we haven't spoken to her personally
just based on what we've been hearing
what they put out publicly um i feel
pretty bad and pretty sad about it
it's tragic i mean she just she doesn't
deserve however bad she feels about
herself because the thing is when she
announced she was retiring
she got a lot well she got a lot of
support but apparently it didn't help
because for whatever reason she feels
awful yeah and she just
announced that they're also quitting the
podcast
and um
i don't know what's going on but i just
feel awful because i know she's a really
good person
the kind of content she's been making
the past several years has just been
totally wholesome
and not problematic in the slightest bit
which is honestly on youtube really
refreshing to see just original content
that's not
basically yeah and no he's been saying
that for the longest time we always
appreciate
how she's just able to continue
her channel and just make this really
silly videos but
obviously people still come people still
watch yeah this
is just this no clickbait i don't know
who this there's all
group of people that dislikes everyone
okay so i know it's hard to imagine that
there's a group of people that dislike
jenna marbles but i'm sure they're out
there
and i think what happens is that these
people will just never let your past go
they'll send like any time you work with
a new sponsor they send it to your
sponsor
anytime you have some kind of
opportunity they spam them they make it
their mission
to make it that your worst moment on the
internet defines your whole life
and people do that to us too yeah and
it's a shame because
there should be a room to change and to
grow you know
uh oh ian's got the guy who wanted
dating advice
all right i'm moving to man one sec this
is awesome this rules
dude this rules ethan and ela after dark
rules
this is awesome this is what i always
wanted yeah wait real quick while he's
lining that up uh
beauville 150 donation i sent for ethan
but ela you are right behind him
love all you guys stay safe heading into
work to make that donation money back
thank you man you didn't need to donate
all your [ __ ] i mean that's
that's beyond generous so are you gonna
put mayonnaise on your head for that guy
dan he didn't specifically ask for that
so i don't necessarily i'm sure he'd
love to see that mom again you got it
thank you to all the members i want to
say that the members is make
all this the membership makes such a
huge difference for us because
we want to keep it going you know we
want to keep it all going so
it's great and we have a new person
starting on monday too
to og we have here a little
vive she said she is
one of the top point two percent of only
friends
oh she's a cam girl for three years if
we want to ask her any questions i would
love to look up her pictures
yeah let's see meanwhile i want to give
this guy some advice
yeah he should be in the lobby what's
his name
hi jaka boyd there he is yakavoid
yaka boy what is that is that your real
name
uh no my name's jack oh jack that's much
easier to say
yeah so jack what is the issue that
we're confronting today
um i've known her for like seven years
how are you you sound on the younger
side
uh i'm 15. oh so when you say seven
years
uh then you've noticed
yeah wow okay so you guys been
friends since for a long long time young
love
yeah yeah
uh and i don't know
what's your question i just have no idea
what to do did you already ask her out
yeah what did she say she said yes
oh young jack
i'm excited you're all such a beautiful
relationship
i gotta know what to do so okay let me
let me uh
let me ask you a few questions jack yeah
how often do you guys talk how often are
you guys together
uh we haven't been together much
recently because of go vid yeah before
coming but
you guys talk on the i mean we went to
school
we had a bunch of classes together
you guys didn't have like a friendly
relationship or anything like that
before you asked her out
uh yeah we did okay you guys ever hang
out dang you shouldn't answer
un under 18 callers about relationships
oh oh yeah you shouldn't
why not i'm not giving them sex advice
don't have sex i mean clearly you're way
too young for that
yeah i'm trying i'm just trying to find
love
yeah i think it's okay but i i do
how old is she uh she's 15
too i think
it sounds like you're right on track
dude i don't know what's the problem
yeah i mean it sounds like she was
receptive what did she say you asked
what did you say to her then what did
she say to you
she said lol yes
but what happened after the lol yes
let me check yes
casual texting well i don't know um
i think you should take advantage of the
fact that it's covered and you can't
really do much anyway
and just talk a lot yeah yeah
talk about the best way to get to know
someone
i think there you go phone chatting
that's that's the key
talk to her and um
yeah i'm bad i'm really bad with uh like
facetiming
i never know what to say you just ask
questions ask her questions
that's like the easy go-to advice if you
you never know what to say
it's just don't worry about saying stuff
yourself just just inquire
just be interested in what she has to
say there you go ask her if she likes
females
yeah we appreciate you jack thanks for
calling
yep and goodbye
oh sorry i meant zach um
ian did you talk to him on the phone
before you brought him in
now you guys said get him in so i just
moved him
now he's great he's he's a good kid he
sounds like he's right on track
here we go jack the legend do you want
to hear oh you want to watch the
bradbury report
yeah oh wait what about the cam girl let
me see some pics
i don't know i don't have picks i mean
if she wants you can call in
oh we got a hundred one what is that
stan cover that
bald dome with mayor
[Music]
no i'm kidding i don't know we might
have males
dan if we have mayo can we get some on
that dome
no come on gross people are giving money
for it
i know well i mean that's the
prerogative but geez
[Music]
just shaved my head like a day ago
on there it'll be my moisturizer exactly
[ __ ] old jar mayo in his hair the
ball you just wipe
you just wipe it right off zach is
willing to debase himself
more than willing you think for the show
dan anything for the show
forever ethan do you like boiled chicken
i've tried it it's super good
boil i like to boil chicken and broth
chicken broth bone broth that kind of
thing yeah it's pretty good
but it tends to you go it just dries out
so fast that
you got to be really delicate with that
everybody [ __ ] spamming about the
mayo now so
so we'll have to get some kind of
fundraiser and we'll we'll get mayo on
your head i'm sure of it
maybe if we plan for it next maybe next
week we can do the mail thing
yeah yeah episode
all right here is the um the big
peak really of of ethanol after dark
so let me set this up this is the
bradbury report
i'm gonna i can't show it to you i'm
just going to play the audio and i know
that sounds lame but
the audio is great it's pretty clear if
i show this to you
he will be arrested and our channel will
be erased
but i want to make it very clear we
don't want to seem like we're
like part of this in any way because
we're not let me make it
very very clear i told
at the very onset of this before people
understood how bad it was
like new york's not even on lockdown yet
that should give you some context yeah
we said ethan wouldn't it be funny to
just go
and ask people what they think about
covid on the street because i was like
ethan would be a great man on the street
segment for the podcast i still do think
that's true by the way we shouldn't
we should probably i want to get ethan
involved in some capacity
yeah love him but so he's like sure i'm
on it and then what he sent us back was
this video
and then when i saw this i was like dude
i can't like this first of all is
horrible
and i can't show it and i wish you
didn't do this
that being said here is the bradbury
report which i condone in the
most extreme possible language
the bradbury report a regular raw
central today in the root of new york
city
what are they saying right now dan as i
play this
right well i mean i can't show it what
do you want me to show put up a picture
of ethan bradbury so we all have a
visual you can do it yeah you can do it
oh there oh you can do it yeah
i don't need you guys just staring at me
weirdly just
watching yeah iconic
oh that's a beauty shot what do you guys
think of this this is he's so beautiful
he's a very handsome man
that's even better all right here we go
you guys tell me what you think of the
bradbury report i'd love to get him back
involved though but you can't do we have
to be like dude you can't do that and
some ground rules
just want to know your thoughts for the
corona
or what yeah what do you what are your
thoughts on the corona
there's even from
i have it that's why you know what i'm
saying i'm just trying to enjoy my last
few moments
i guess we're enjoying the video the
thing about ethan is like
what he's saying could be construed as
funny but
the way he delivers it with dead is he
doesn't do deadpan
he does deadly pan yeah
you can't tell what is going on with him
i guess yeah
all right man stay safe god bleach
stay safe can i show this part yeah
because like
i don't think he coughs he just
awkwardly
so he just awkwardly um
well here he makes the guy walk away
yeah please
stay safe he stays yeah
this one is so i wish i could show this
one
oh i can't get it i got to show this
because even the part of him trying to
get in the cab
yeah it's so ridiculous like like just
just me
all right now i gotta take this
off-screen we'll release the full
footage when there is a
and i'm saying but uh
before i go like um
i'm with i'm with the regular raw
central today
huh yeah um what do you think of the
coronavirus
i don't know why the only thing i can
say in his defense is that
it was before
it was just starting to get really bad
yeah like new york's not on lockdown
i just i was like dude just ask people
don't go coughing on people and act
pretending you have coronavirus
what you won't go one more no what do
you think about the corona virus
i don't know i have no idea how they
have to do he's sitting up front of this
guy
i have it so so why you called you so i
thought
i told you go over there i mean what the
hell is wrong with you dude
ah this is so bad morat what's wrong but
i want to sit in the front
whoa let's go over there man
listen i have i have a few you know
moments can you open the door
he's driving off and his cameraman is on
the street
go where you are
uh can you weigh a little because yeah
i mean should we keep watching i feel
bad no yeah that was it
i started to feel bad right here and it
gets worse
oh we just we've teased it before and
people kept asking so like
now people know yeah they know wait i
understand why we couldn't show it i
actually do want to show this part with
that one
everybody's saying they wanted to see
your reactions um he's real
oh nice you this part i don't think he
coughs during this part but
he just he doesn't let this guy go away
he just
keeps take keeping him there i visit
there a lot
did you start where i love it over there
i go to tel aviv you know around there
i don't know why this guy's i'm from the
heart of brooklyn
what is it you know
oh this poor guy
[Music]
uh posted private or posted on twitter
but that's not the point the point is
ethan's gonna get arrested if this
finishes
well hopefully i'm not liable no you no
i didn't meant the other
thing oh dude ethan we're all named
ethan
so um we're approaching an hour and a
half which is basically how long i
wanted this to be
do we have one more call we can get in
here and see if we got something
interesting to discuss with the
people of the world people of the h3
niche
uh everyone just wants this guy to come
in who's talking about
nuts okay bring the nut guy in all right
i'll bring the nut guy he's going
is he how old is he in just make sure
it's like you know
i'll confirm like 18 plus yeah in the
meantime we got another 50
donation a moment ago
someone wants me to take my shirt off
dan you drive a hard bargain here
is here's 50 up front all you got to do
is promise to give chili's a second
chance oh it's oh this is mega awesome
nerd okay i was arguing with this guy
about chili's in the uh
in the discord the other day chili's is
not asked here it's not
and for like chain restaurants they were
they were trying to rape chain
restaurants and he's
really convinced that well chili's i
will say some restaurants chili's has
these
bomb [ __ ] nachos where they do
like they put like 10
chips on the plate and then they make
sure each chip is perfect
perfect beans cheese jalapeno sour cream
and it's like each chip is [ __ ]
perfect
and that my friends is that
here sorry dan really um you're going
with chili's
let's get the nuts guy in okay i haven't
had it in a while though so i don't know
oh zach agrees
yeah you want to go to chili's tonight
um we were saying that we should private
that video
because you showed uh oh private at dan
link url
i don't think it's i don't know who
uploaded that here let me see where is
it
good point you guys um
it's unlisted to
oh [ __ ] it already has 100 it already
has 22 likes what the [ __ ]
you guys are crazy can you copy that
yeah and here's the nut guy right now
all right give me his name introduce him
hi
nutman hello what's your name
uh my name is kevin on discord i am k
and sasaki
so why is everybody trying to get you on
the show to discuss
nuts well for the past week we've been
had a heated debate
on the discord about a nut tier list and
so i was wondering if we can go over a
nut tier list with you guys
sure what did you guys uh what did you
guys decide
so uh as s tier i have almonds and
macadamia nuts
almonds for sure macadamias for me are
not ester but almonds are definitely
used here i don't know about macadamia
being honest
no it's not it's not us it's it's the
best tasting
in my opinion they're like i mean
they're good but there's always like
that thing about it that's not good it's
too nutty it's like
it's like too much yeah like why are
they soaked
i don't want to commit to a whole nut
moment
you know what i mean yeah yeah i think
almond is indisputably the only s
tier because almond is like sure now
almond is just so versatile
it does everything it's so versatile you
can make milk cut
i mean [ __ ] right wait so we're talking
about what you could also make of it
oh ian gave me the okay wait i have the
s tier
the nut classification here on my screen
oh very nice so
oh pistachios are definitely a i love
pistachios and peanuts and cashews you
guys are right on
okay so if we're if we're thinking about
it that way i may have to take back my
um opinion on macadamia because you make
really bomb
stuff from that like a mac nut crusted
fish or chicken me personally
no not you personally i mean in food oh
because you can do
like using it in cooking not just like
chocolate it's amazing yeah that's
pretty cool yeah but we're talking about
the nut right we're not talking about
what we gave almond credit for all the
things you can do with it yeah but
are we just talking about eating a
straight nut or just no no
no all abilities i think you guys did a
pretty good job here honestly
it's looking decent like anything past a
i don't know wait a minute i
hold on i told you guys to take coconut
off of this list
coconut is not a nut it's not a nut
that's true
yeah it's a definition
wait why the [ __ ] is acorn on here are
you
are you kidding me what are you doing
the most popular nut
for squirrels
i i can't rate acorn
are you a squirrel right i'm a fan of
squirrels without acorns
then like we lose uh squirrels and ice
cubes
why is walnut at f
walnuts she's
walnuts are by far the worst nut i am
totally with him that's crazy
i think you guys have got it right on
what about pecan shouldn't it be a
no because it's a very pecan pie going
forward that's it i think it's a good
dessert nut but other than that it
doesn't have much going for it
i recently just found out that peanuts
were actually not nuts
okay let's not get into that
all right well this is fascinating
anything else what's your name kevin
uh yeah kevin kevin and can i give uh
one shout out
yeah uh so there's a 33 year old boomer
on a discord called nyam and she's a
white boomer that
married a japanese guy and moved to
japan
why is she defeated by a boomer why are
you shouting her out
she just has boomer takes why are you
shouting her out
is this a title she is number one on
discord so she does deserve a shout out
what's her name nyan
she's married you say yeah to a japanese
guy
and her daughter doesn't speak english
okay well great shout out to her we
appreciate
her then well okay kevin thank you for
the nut tier list i'm captivated and i
think you guys are right on i think you
guys nailed it right now what's up with
the coconut and get that [ __ ] off of
there
all right well guys that's about an hour
and a half i think i had a lot of fun
i just wanted a session oh i also do all
these right i don't know if you guys
want to do this but i i got the girl
with the only fans girl you wanted to
talk to yes bring her bring
but but what's her name i want to see
pics i want to see what she does
i just need some context i'm not trying
to beat my meat i just want to know what
she does
what's her name ian was it little view
uh viv vivian uh hold on i'm moving her
right now
i don't think anything came up when i
typed that not a little bit
well she'll tell us um all right she's
in now
a little low viv
little viv small viv looks like her
mike's
mike's muted your mike's muted viv some
kind of cam girl she is
oh hey what's your name on the internet
yeah yeah if it sounds like you have the
stream open in the background
you got to mute the stream
all right thank you little bib for the
call appreciate that
yeah oh am i in
not anymore not anymore you blew it you
blew it viv
thank you viv is there anything else we
want to talk about i do want to say
shout out to all these rallies
in the chat dude pewdiepie came by
became a tier three sub and saw my feet
i mean i feel like this was a really
good first year success
yeah i feel like i'm super happy with
ethan and ela
after dark episode one you know what i
would love from you guys if you have
more after dark suggestions
of the wild side of the internet you'd
like us to watch on discord we have a
really
vibrant suggestion room is that right
guys
so if somebody suggests something good
you guys will see it right eitan
what all right they want to hear
something in hebrew from you
ani
ani of vedic
you just said i uh working in female
bread what i didn't say that
ani nice
i like bread okay
got him nicely done uh
so if they suggest something if they
suggest something you guys will see it
on that discord room right
we we are frequently in the discord uh
we are checking it out we see your
suggestions so bring them along and yeah
now that we've done this first stream i
think there were a lot of questions of
what the stream was going to be how it's
going to flow and everything
obviously i think people have a better
impression of that now so um
yeah the the too hot for tv vids
for tv exactly but not sexual not like
no nobody
being murdered we'll send that and we'll
decide yeah we'll we'll filter it send
it
just send it and people saying you need
the discord link you you don't it's not
a link you just gotta link your discord
to
your youtube uh account that's it what
does that mean is that self-explanatory
because i don't know what that means
well you want me to give the explanation
this connections tab
in the discord settings and you from
there you link
your youtube account that you've become
a member on to your discord account
at that point you will have the option
to join the discord if you are on an
iphone you will not see it because
iphones suck and for whatever reason
it's just not there on an iphone so if
you're experiencing that just go on a
browser
don't use the app on the iphone it sucks
and that's
working on it um but but
that's really cool that they do that
with discordant through the yeah it's a
pretty slick integration
so yeah once you're a member um it it
you can do that and you can join our
community
so the israelis are triggered that
everyone says my name wrong can you try
to say it right
well it's like you know yeah it doesn't
really
roll hard to say it like it's like the
english version of it yeah
it's hard to say if you're not a native
it's just
it's weird to be like so anyway
just it doesn't work you just have to
shout it no no no
no inflection is on like it's like
you're not like
hilan
[Laughter]
yeah i i speak hebrew to theodore
so i do think he's gonna know both
languages that's cool
yeah he learned he's now says instead of
strawberry he says
and um i said like today we were talking
to my mom on the phone
and we said give her a kiss and he did
it and we said it in april
oh wow that's so cool yeah
oh my god what a little legend yeah
all right guys um next week we'll be
back i think we want to typically stream
ever
on fridays at 12. so you can expect us
around then next week but
this was a hit i i think we all had so
much fun it was a great turnout
thank you guys thank you to all the
members for the donators this was a
great great time
ethan and eela after dark will continue
three episodes a week
count them boom boom boom guess what i
got a fourth an idea for
fourth episode i love it
i have an idea for a fourth episode
coming soon when we move into our new
studio the content
out the ears out the ears and uh to
anybody super chat if we didn't get to
it i
apologize again there was a lot of them
and we were trying to keep things
flowing but we do love you and
appreciate you
and uh thank you for that all right guys
so monday andrew yang and then you know
take it from there right the regular
next week um
well it always gets confusing we're
recording next week but i guess it
doesn't come out until
the following monday well we have cody
code we have cody excited about that
yeah so codyco
being recorded next week uh it'll be up
for members at the end of the week and
for non-members uh the following monday
so the lives are going to continue to be
on fridays yes that's the goal
cool nintendo after dark
edgy exciting
you never know what you ex gonna see
might be ethan bradbery coughing on
people and it might be
some lady getting put in a hole in the
living room
it's just crazy all right guys
we'll see you uh we'll see you then have
a great weekend all right appreciate you
tata